-We have exactly four shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters! Here we go!
-♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Four days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is right!
Every show between now
and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a "Return of the Mack"-adocious
Christmas sweater
from the Countdown
to Christmas cabinet.
Since there are four shows left,
let's open door number four.
[ Drum roll ]
Right here.
Whenever you're ready. Yeah.
Thank you very...
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Bells jingling ]
This is nice here.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh. Look at that.
Wow. This is fantastic. Alright.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
I need you to jump up
and let me know where you are.
Quest,
can I get a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
Who wants me to pick
their numbers to get one?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go!
420!
♪♪
That's a good one right there...
Hey, bud. How you doing?
Come on over.
♪♪
Nice to see you.
-It's nice to see you, too!
-How are you?
-I'm doing great.
-What is your name?
-My name is Julia.
I'm from Virginia.
-From Virginia! Julia is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All the way from Virginia.
Now, Julia, you look very nice,
but it gets --
it gets chilly in Virginia.
-It does.
-Yeah. And you have sweaters.
And you have, you know,
things to wear.
-Yeah. Not enough, though.
This is -- This will be
the perfect addition.
-And if you're out at night,
I'm just saying...
You know, it's safety.
Safety is sexy, you know?
That's what I always say.
-Yeah.
-Would you like to try this on?
-I would love to.
-I think this will be --
This will go great
with the dress.
It'll go great with the dress,
I think.
Good luck.
-We're almost there.
-Yeah. That's right.
It's not easy to get into,
but...
-Where's the head?
-Oh, yeah. No. That's good.
Ohh! Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Knock-out!
Are you kidding me?
Thank you so much.
You look fantastic.
Happy holidays. Good to see you.